lo sentimos
[Música]
hola a todos bienvenidos a los
observadores de france 24 esta semana
vamos hasta líbano allí nuestro
observador nos mostrará las nuevas
consecuencias concretas de la crisis
económica que está afectando incluso a
las estaciones de combustible luego
iremos a bangladesh donde unas cercas
que fueron levantadas alrededor de un
campamento de refugiados rohingya
preocupa a diferentes asociaciones
amamos
peleas que a veces terminan en disparos
en líbano filas interminables delante de
las estaciones de gasolina ponen a
prueba los nervios de los habitantes la
causa escasez de gasolina y una subida
de los precios o la consecuencia de la
grave crisis económica que sacude el
país
nuestro observador vive en beirut narra
la odisea de los conductores de walt
meses para lograr encontrar una
gasolinera cada vez que voy a poner
gasolina debo esperar tres o cuatro
horas bajo un sol ardiente ahora estoy
en la fila y es posible que haya cientos
de carros detrás mío tal vez puedo
mostrarles lo que pasa aquí por cientos
de metros
además de las pilas delante de las
estaciones de gasolina el trancón es
terribles
a veces la autopista está bloqueada
durante dos o tres horas porque hay
demasiados carros haciendo fila por
gasolina
cuando un conductor hace la fila durante
dos o tres horas
y un energúmeno se le adelanta eso causa
una disputa que puede convertirse en una
pelea o incluso resultar en disparos
[Música]
más recientemente google hashtag en
twitter las filas de la humillación es
el hashtag más compartido en el líbano
en efecto es una situación humillante
les estoy hablando y ya he estado tres
horas haciendo la fila hay
manifestaciones diarias en líbano creo
que se van a incrementar ayer unos
manifestantes bloquearon vías en varias
regiones del país la escasez se agravó
con el contrabando de gasolina hacia
siria que está muy extendido por con
líbano la gasolina está subvencionada
por el estado y es tres veces más barata
que en el país es miles de litros de
gasolina son interceptados a diario en
la frontera concilia y todos los días
hay comunicados del ejército con
imágenes a veces hay enfrentamientos con
los contrabandistas el ministro libanés
de energía remón ghajar declaró el 17 de
junio del precio de la gasolina volvería
a subir y que las personas que no tengan
los medios para comprarla tendrán que
buscar nuestra manera para desplazarse
cómo puede decir eso estas declaraciones
van a hacer que la gente almacene
masivamente en sus casas en lugares
donde hay niños mujeres y una fuerte
densidad de habitantes y ya hubo varios
incendios porque las personas almacenan
gasolina y visas
hay amor de 70 logístico al aire
sobre eso
600 hombres son refugiados rohingya que
tratan de llevar el cuerpo de uno de los
suyos al cementerio pero se enfrentan a
las cercas de alambre de púas levantadas
en los últimos meses por las autoridades
de bangladesh alrededor y entre cada
campamento nuestro observador trata
desde londres de movilizarse contra
estas cercas que considera peligrosas y
humillantes
lo que se instaló fueron cercas con
alambre de púas con alambre que sólo
tienen púas y también con alambres
concertina que tienen cuchillas estos
últimos son muy difíciles de atravesar y
a los niños les parecen muy atractivos
porque son en forma de tubo de las ganas
de meterse adentro y de jugar no tienen
lugar para jugar por eso terminan
cortándose al meterse ahí adentro la
instalación no tuvo en cuenta que podría
volver algunos servicios más o menos
accesibles hay personas que tuvieron que
mover sus casas para instalarse dentro
de la zona cercada deben recorrer
distancias mucho más largas a pie ir a
la clínica se volvió muy difícil para
las personas mayores los enfermos son
las mujeres embarazadas es una manera de
castigar a los refugiados es una manera
muy autoritaria de tratar a personas que
sufrieron un genocidio y que son
vulnerables en este momento
en situaciones de emergencia como cuando
hubo un incendio el 22 de marzo pasado
en el que muchas personas murieron
incluidos niños jóvenes en
circunstancias aterradoras los alambres
de púas les impidieron escaparse el
incendio de buscado por nuestro
observador traumatizó a los refugiados
dejando 15 muertos y más de 500 heridos
un balance que según las ong habría sido
menos grave sin la presencia de las
cercas tras este incidente nació la
campaña remove the fence kit en la cerca
en español para denunciar su presencia y
exigir su retiro
entre las razones dadas por el gobierno
de bangladesh para justificar la
instalación de las cercas un aspecto es
la seguridad de los bangladesíes ante la
afluencia de rohingyas de 2017 y los
rohingyas son asociados con supuestos
tráficos de drogas tráfico de seres
humanos y demás es el tipo de carne ese
tipo de retórica y ese tipo de
sensacionalismo que hay en la prensa
local y que se puede encontrar en
bangladesh
de más de 800.000 rohingyas están
refugiados en bangladesh desde 2017
habían oído de los ataques del ejército
de mianmar calificados de limpieza
étnica y de genocidio por la onu
gracias a todos nuestros observadores
por sus reportes si usted quiere ser
parte del equipo de los observadores
puede entrar en contacto con la
producción del programa todos los datos
de contacto aparecen en sus pantallas
esperamos sus fotos sus vídeos y también
sus historias hasta pronto